الان اذا نقرا عسكريا ما يجري مع اللواء
فايز الدويري اهلا بك سياده اللواء سنتحدث
عن كل ذلك ولكن قبل ذلك نذهب الى صهيب
العصا لتقربنا اكثر من الصوره على الخارطه
التفاعليه
ولعلنا نتحدث عن هذا النفق الذي تم الحديث
عن اكتشافه ايضا صحيح صحيح عثمان نتحدث عن
اكتشاف ان صح التعبير مهم وفق روايه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ونتحدث بطبيعه الحال عن
المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه هذا
بالاضافه الى المعارك البريه في المنطقه
الشماليه ومنطقه خان يونس ولكن اذا ما
بدانا الحديث عن النفق المكتشف وفقى
الروايه الاسرائيليه فنحن نتحدث عن هذه
المناطق بطبيعه الحال المنطقه الشماليه من
قطاع غزه كما نشاهد على الخريطه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قالت ان ان النفق
يمتد بعمق اربعه كيلومترات من السياج
الفاصل هناك بعض بعض النقاط المهمه يجب
ملاحظتها ومعرفتها في هذه المنطقه عند
عندما نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن نقطه
ايرز وهي نقطه عسكريه ومستوطن صغيره ومعبر
ايرز الذي يمر منه الفلسطينيون باتجاه
مناطق داخل اسرائيل ونتحدث عن بيت حنون
هذا المعبر اسمه معبر بيت حنون ايرز لانه
يقع في اراضي بلده بيت حنون في الشمال
الشرقي من مدينه غزه وفق الروايه
الاسرائيليه فان هذا المعبر يمتد الى
اربعه كيلومترات داخل النفق داخل داخل
قطاع غزه واذا ما تحدثنا عن الاربعه
كيلومترات فنحن نتحدث عن هذه المسافه وفق
الرسم الذي رسمه الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم
المعبر يسير بهذا الشكل ويلتقي بشارع صلاح
الدين في هذه النقطه ثم يمتد اد هذه
النقطه هذا الرسم الازرق الذي نشاهده هذا
الخط الازرق الذي نشاهده لا تتجاوز مسافته
كيلو و300 متر وفق تحليل الصور التي نشرها
الجيش الاسرائيلي والخريطه التي وضعها
الجيش الاسرائيلي ولكن الجيش قال بان هذا
النفق يمتد الى منطقه جباليا اذا ما تم
بالفعل الحديث عن ان هذا النفق يمتد الى
منطقه المنطقه الشماليه من مخيم جباليا
هنا ياتي الحديث منطقيا بشكل نسبي اذا
نتحدث عن كل هذه المسافه باللونين الازرق
والاصفر هذه المسافه تصبح 4 كيلومترات
ولكن ما نشره الجيش الاسرائيلي يتوقف عند
هذه النقطه وبالتالي الحديث عن هذه هذه
الجزئيه هي تقريبا كيلو و300 متر اذا ما
اخذنا بعين الاعتبار المسافه داخل الا اذا
تم الاعتراف لاحقا بان هذا النفق عبر
الحدود ونتحدث حينها عن نقطه ايرز اي ان
النفق ربما وصل الى نقطه ايرز اذا ما
حسبنا كل هذه المسافه من نقطه ايرز الى
المعبر الى النقطه التي رسمها الاحتلال
بهذا الشكل اللون الاصفر او اللون الاحمر
ال شاهده هكذا تصبح المسافه حوالي 4
كيلومترات اذا لدينا رسم من القوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ولدينا رسم تقريبي
اخر يوضح مسافه الاربعه كيلومترات لهذا
النفق اذا هو موضوع مهم التفصيل فيه ومهم
معرفه ايه معالم هذا النفق ومسافه هذا
النفق الذي دخلها ان انه اذا ما دخل داخل
المناطق الاسرائيليه فهذا يعتبر تحولا
نوعيا في ساحه القتال ويعتبر ايضا اكتشافا
مهما بسير المعارك اذا ما ذهبنا الى
المعارك على الارض فنحن نتحدث عن محاور
مهمه للقتال في المنطقه الشماليه وفق
اعلانات كتاب القسام والجيش الاسرائيلي
نتحدث عن قتال مستمر مازال في الشجاعيه
شرق مدينه غزه ونتحدث عن قتال مستمر على
اطراف مخيم جباليا وتحديدا اطراف الغربيه
من مخيم جباليا مع محاولات احتلال
اسرائيلي لاختراق الشجاعيه والوصول الى
قلب مدينه غزه في هذه النقطه بالاضافه الى
الضغط على مخيم جباليه نذهب سريعا الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه ونتحدث عن
مدينه خانيونس ومنطقه القراره والمنطقه
الوسطى مدينه خان يونس بطبيعه الحال في
المنطقه الجنوبيه يضغط الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من الجهه الشرقيه من جهه عبسان
وبن سهيلا من جهه الشماليه الشرقيه من جهه
الزنه ومشاهد التي شاهدناها قبل قليل
لمروحيات اسرائيليه ربما انها تسعف جرحى
اسرائيليين في منطقه القراره في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه اعلانات كتاب القسام
تقول بانها تتصدى للاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
اذا ما تم اكتشاف انفاق اخرى هذه
المعلومات بحاجه الى تحليل وستكون به هذه
التغطيه معك عثمان اليك